solve the following application problem
using three equations with three
unknowns and they tell us the second
angle of a triangle is fifty degrees
less than four times the first angle the
third angle is 40 degrees less than the
first find the measures of the three
angles so let's draw ourselves a
triangle here let's say that the let's
call the first angle a the second angle
B and then the third angle C and before
we even look at these constraints one
property we know of triangles is that
the sum of their angles must be 180
degrees so we know that a plus B plus C
must be equal to 180 degrees now with
that out of the way let's look at these
other constraints so they tell us the
second angle the second angle of a
triangle let me do that in another color
they tell us the second angle of a
triangle is 50 degrees less than four
times the first angle so we're saying B
is the second angle so they're saying
the second angle of a triangle is fifty
degrees less than four times the first
angle so four times the first angle
would be 4a we're calling a the first
angle so four times the first angle is
4a but it's fifty degrees less than that
so minus minus 50 now the next
constraint they give us the third angle
is 40 degrees less than the first so the
third angle is 40 degrees less than the
first so the first angle is a and it's
going to be 40 degrees less than that so
we have three equations with three
unknowns and so we just have to solve
for and let's see what's the good first
variable to try to eliminate and just to
try to visualize that a little bit
better I'm going to bring I'm going to
bring these A's on to the left-hand side
of each of these equations over here so
I'm going to rewrite the first equation
we have a plus B plus C is equal to 180
and then this equation if we subtract 4a
from both sides of this equation if we
subtract 4a we have negative 4 a plus B
is equal to net
negative is equal to negative 50 and
then this equation right over here if we
subtract a from both sides we get
negative a negative a pull negative a
plus C negative a plus C is equal to
negative 40 I just subtracted a from
both sides so we now want to eliminate
variables and we already have this third
equation here is only in terms of a and
C this is only in terms of a and B and
this first one is terms of a B and C so
if we could let's see this is already in
terms of a and see if we could turn
these first two equations if we can use
the information in these first two
equations to end up with an equation
that's only in terms of a and C then we
could use whatever we end up with along
with this third equation right over here
and we'll have a system of two equations
with two unknowns so let's do that so if
we wanted to just end up with an
equation only in terms of a and C using
these first two we would want to
eliminate the bees so we could multiply
one of these equations times negative
one and one of these positive bees would
turn into a negative B so let's do that
let's multiply this first equation over
here let's multiply it times negative
one times negative one so it'll become
negative a minus B minus C is equal to
negative 180 and then we have this green
equation right over here which is really
just this equation just rearranged so we
have negative 4a plus B is equal to
negative 50 and now we can add these two
equations actually should have done that
in the actually let me do it at the
other color just so you see where that's
coming from do it in that green color so
this is negative 4 a plus B is equal to
negative 50 we can add these two up now
and we get we get negative a minus 4a is
negative 5a the B's cancel out we have a
minus C is equal to negative 180 minus
50 is negative 230 so now using these
top two equations we have an equation
only in terms of a and C we have another
equation only in terms of a and C it
looks like if we add them together their
C's will cancel out so let me just
rewrite this equation over here and you
have to be careful that you're using all
of the equations otherwise you'll kind
of do a circular argument you have to be
careful that over here this first
equation came from these two over here
now I want to combine that with this
third constraint a constraint that's not
already baked into this equation right
over here so we have negative a plus C
is equal to negative 4t and we add these
two equations negative 5a minus a is
negative 6a the C's cancel out and then
you have negative 230 minus 40 this is
equal to negative 270 we can divide both
sides by negative 6 by negative 6 and we
get a is equal to negative 270 over 6
let me see how many times let me see
something
270 is divisible by both 3 & 2 so it
should be divisible by 6 so let me just
divide it the negative signs obviously
will a negative divided by a negative is
going to be a positive if we take 6 into
276 goes into 27 4 times 4 times 6 is 24
we subtract we get 3 bring down the 0 6
goes into 35 times so we get a is equal
to a is equal to a is equal to 45 now
let's look at the other ones we can
substitute back in to solve for C C is
equal to a minus 40 degrees a minus 40
degrees so that is equal to let me write
it right over here in yellow so C is
equal to 45 minus 40 which is equal to 5
degrees so so far we have a is equal to
45 degrees C is equal to 5 degrees C is
equal to 5 degrees and then you could
substitute into either one of these
other ones to figure out B we could use
this one right over here in green V is
equal to 4a minus 50 so B is going to be
equal to 4 times 45 is let's see 2 times
45 is 90 so 4 times 45 is 180 so it's
going to be 100
eighty 180 minus 50 by this equation
right over here which is equal to 130
degrees so we get B is equal to 130
degrees and then we can let me write it
over here so a is equal to 45 so if
actuator order if I wanted to draw this
triangle it would actually look
something like this
a is a 45 degree angle B is 130 degree
angle and and C is five so it looks
it'll look something like it looks
something like this
it will look something like this where
this is a at 45 degrees B is 135 degrees
and then C is five degrees and you can
verify that it works one you can just
add up the angles 45 plus five is fifty
I'm sorry this isn't 135 it's 130 we
solved it right over here 130 and this
is five so when you add them all up 45
plus 130 plus five that does indeed
equal 180 degrees 45 plus five is fifty
plus 130 so this does definitely equal
180 so it meets our first constraint
then on our second constraint B needs to
be equal to 4a minus 50 well 4 times a 4
times a is 180 minus 50 is 130 degrees
so it meets our second constraint and
then our third constraint C is a minus
40 degrees well a is 45 C is 5 so if you
subtract 40 from 45 you get 5 which is C
so it meets all of our constraints and
we are done